Будьмо відвертими: Анґела Меркель -
не надто харизматична політикиня.
Тож зовсім не тому близько двох третин жителів Німеччини
схвалюють її діїв часи коронавірусу.
Секрет її успіху, схоже, полягає у спокійній
і стриманій манері та науковому підході.
Фірмовий знак Меркель - це руки "ромбиком".
Погляньмо уважно на її стратегію від самого початку коронакризи.
Що характерно для Меркель - вона
не поспішала робити заяви в перші дні пандемії.
Багато хто вважає, що вона чекала задовго.
Але коли Меркель нарешті виступила, то стала першою зі світових лідерів,
хто прямо озвучив жахливі факти.
Потрібно розуміти, що якщо вірус вже серед нас,
а у людей немає імунітету, і поки не існує вакцини або ліків,
то значна частина населення -
від 60 до 70% - буде заражена.
Як правильно сказала канцлерка, мова йде про пандемічний вірус.
Це означає, що ним заразиться 60-70 відсотків населення.
Я була свідком того, як Анґела Меркель фактично передала
керівництво провідним науковцям Німеччини.
Поки експерти в інших країнах сперечалися з політиками,
Меркель була готова слухати фахівців.
Ми будемо ухвалювати політичні рішення
відповідно до рекомендацій експертів.
Німців не довелося довго переконувати,
адже вони вже бачили жахливі кадри
з лікарень на півночі Італії.
Коли оголосили карантин, Анґела Меркель
вперше за понад 14 років свого правління
виступила із незапланованим зверненням,
закликавши жителів країни бути відповідальними,
при цьому не обіцяючи хепі-енду.
Ситуація серйозна  і відкрита.
Відкрита демократія передбачає,
що ми ухвалюємо політичні рішення прозоро і роз’яснюємо їх.
Ми обґрунтовуємо та повідомляємо про свої дії
якомога краще, щоб вони були зрозумілими.
Німеччині вдалося вирівняти криву заражень,
не перевантажуючи систему охорони здоров'я.
Меркель назвала це крихким успіхом, а багато регіонів
почали повертатися до нормального життя.
Але канцлерка не поспішала святкувати.
Вона діяла як сувора наставниця 16 глав федеральних земель.
Деякі з них, на її думку, занадто поквапилися,
оголосивши, що найгірше вже позаду.
Ніхто не хоче таке чути, але це правда:
заключна фаза пандемії ще не настала.
Ми все ще на самому її початку.
Нам доведеться ще довго жити з цим вірусом.
Порожні лікарняні ліжка у Німеччині -
це свідчення успіху політики Анґели Меркель.
І хоча тисячі людей виходили на вулиці по всій Німеччині,
протестуючи проти дій Меркель,
опитування показують, що це лише "гучна" меншість.
Понад 80 відсотків німців підтримують запроваджені обмеження.
Утім, коронавірус також виявив один із найсерйозніших провалів
політики Меркель за майже півтора десятка років її правління.
А саме - брак цифрових технологій, через що школам
і багатьом підприємствам довелося дуже непросто під час самоізоляції.
Відсутність прогресу при розробці програми для відстеження заражених COVID-19,
яка вже використовується у Південній Кореї, підтверджує:
підхід ФРН до вирішення цього історичного виклику застарів.
Але коли справа доходить до проблем, які Меркель ще не обдумала,
вона просто просить дати їй трохи часу.
І це відрізняє її від інших світових лідерів.
Щоб сформувати думку, мені потрібно ще пару годин, пане Фоґель.
Я дам вам знати.
Схоже, головний секрет успіху Анґели Меркель
полягає у відсутності секрету.
Вона готова визнавати, що чогось не знає.
В результаті рейтинг Меркель, яку ще два місяці тому
називали "кульгавою качкою",
зараз стрімко зростає.
А багато її прихильників і критиків не уявляють,
якою буде Німеччина після відходу Меркель восени 2021 року.